and was it like a quick connection very
quick as you said God puts it on Fast
Forward yeah it was just there it was
like okay this all it all it all very it
made sense you know it's like when
you're you know you're doing a puzzle
yes and then you there's a piece and
you're like I'm certain that's the piece
and you like kind of jam it and it's
like it looks like it should be the
piece right and then you're like no me
is it oh it's that one like it just fits
together you're like oh that's okay it
fits because it's the piece that was
made to fit there that felt like that
did you always have access to this kind
of depth or did you have to earn not
until the moment I sat right down in
this chair
I think you have this magic ability to
pull inside of people